down the ages fast Allah sent his
messengers to deliver humankind from
darkness to light invite all to the way
of thy Lord with wisdom and beautiful
preaching and argue with them in the
ways that are best and most gracious
that's also the ongoing mission of
Islamic Research Foundation or IRS
spreading the truth of Allah's final
message to mankind founded in 1991 IRF
today offers some of the best services
and facilities in the world for
presenting an understanding of Islam in
an objective and scientific way its
programs are primarily focused on
correcting misconceptions and promoting
understanding of Islam IRF also imparts
Dawa training to the eyes to applicant
read the message of Islam Aref has one
of the most modern studios producing
programs presenting Islam which have
beamed regularly on many international
TV channels in over 150 countries dr.
Zakir Naik president of RF reaching out
across countries worldwide from America
to Europe to Africa to Asia to Australia
strives to clarify Islamic viewpoints he
dispels the many media myths and anti
Islamic prejudices propagated the world
over by anti Islamic forces dr. Zakir
Naik is a medical doctor
he's acclaimed the world over for his
spontaneous and convincing replies to
questions posed by critics and skeptics
during the question and answer sessions
after his stalls
he is also renowned for his verbatim
quotes with references from major
religious scriptures of the world
dr. zakir and other faculty of the irf
trained many dyes ineffective Dawa
techniques
IRFs website provides freed our training
material for you to download and become
an effective dye dr. zakir naik stocks
are available on audio and video
cassettes cds and dvds the world over RF
today is creating a change in the hearts
and minds of millions of Muslims and
non-muslims worldwide it was a proper
understanding and respect for Islam have
a question or doubt about Islam and its
teachings now you know one of the best
resource centers to get convincing
answers from is Islamic Research
Foundation 56:58 Kendall Street North
dungaree Mumbai four zero zero zero zero
nine India phone two three seven three
six eight seven five fax nine 1 2 2 2 3
7 3 0 6 8 9 email Islam at the rate of
RF dotnet for more information log on to
our web site wwii RF dotnet
we start a program with recital from the
Quran by a young Kerry for yes I am
miss me
does not claw brother the translation of
the street says I was a lineman shaitana
regime he does that we test some of them
by others that they should say is it
these than that Allah has favored from
amongst us does not Allah know best
those who are grateful when those come
to thee who believe in assigns say peace
be on you your Lord has inscribed for
himself the rule of mercy verily if any
of you did evil in ignorance and
thereafter repented and amended his
conduct lo he is oft-forgiving most
merciful
so the class or the colossi respected
chairman brothers and sisters I welcome
you all with Islamic greeting
assalamu alaikum where i met a lie over
Qatar may peace mercy and blessing of
Allah be on all of you it is a privilege
today to have amidst us a speaker who
needs no introduction an Islamic scholar
par excellence
a person who has traveled the world US
Europe Middle East the Far East
delivering lectures on various Islamic
talks and comparative religion the list
is exhaustive now I would like to hand
over the stage under further proceedings
from you to brother Elias Sheikh he'll
conduct the proceedings from Europe
respected elders brothers and sisters I
greet you all with the Islamic greeting
assalamu alaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh may peace mercy and
blessings of Almighty Allah be on all of
you let me now introduce you to our
guest speaker today dr. Zakir Naik dr.
Zakir Naik the president of the Islamic
Research Foundation is a dynamic
international orator on Islam and
comparative religion he is the main
driving spirit alhamdulillah behind the
Islamic Research Foundation getting
worldwide acclaim for the proper
presentation understanding and
clarification on Islam as well as
removing misconceptions about Islam
though a medical doctor by professional
training he has turned around to spread
the real truth of Islam especially to
the millions of english-speaking
audiences throughout the world at only
33 years of age dr. Zakir explains the
teachings of Islam and clears
misconceptions with convincing answers
to challenging questions posed by
members of the audience and skeptics in
question and answer sessions that
followers that regularly follow his
programs
he has also delivered more than 200
public talks in the last two years alone
in the United States of America Canada
United Kingdom Saudi Arabia Bahrain UAE
Kuwait Qatar and Sri Lanka and Malaysia
in addition to many public talks in
India itself he has also participated in
symposiums with prominent personalities
of other faiths dr. Zakir has appeared
on various international TV shows
satellite television programmes in the
United States of America Malaysia India
and so on he is appeared on interactive
radio talk shows in the United States of
America South Africa and several
the countries he is regularly quizzed
and interviewed by media worldwide
especially on topics like why Islam
conflicts with women's rights with human
rights with modern science in secure ISM
but his dynamic resort to dispel media
myths about Islam with facts specific
references and dynamic resolve and
proper context stand out to rectify or
neutralize the prejudice or media bias
that are based on unwarranted
presumptions and conclusions more than
100 dr. jacques lectures and debates and
symposia are available on video and
audio cassettes he has authored books on
Islam and comparative religion I now
call upon brother Jacques at night to
take the mic and deliver the talk on
today's topic if the label shows your
intent where it alhamdulillah wa salatu
was-salam wall rasool allah allah allah
he was happy i mean i'm Abad al billah
min ash-shaytani r-rajim bismillahi
r-rahmani r-rahim la Perlas inna Yamuna
Bai Athena
fawful salam-o-alaikum bismillah
r-rahman r-rahim for easily eaten with a
Adam for high you be asana min ha or do
ha inna llaha can allah pollution
hashiba
bismillah r-rahman r-rahim rubbish
really sorry well sir liamri Mahalo
okhta tamela's ani Jeff Crowley
respected chairman brasilia's my
respects to elder's
and my dear brothers and sisters I
welcome all of you with the Islamic
greetings
assalamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatu
may peace mercy and blessings of allah
subhana WA Ta'ala
be on all of you the topic I have chosen
for this morning's talk is if
the label shows your intent where it it
is rather an unusual topic people may
wonder that what has the label got to do
with Islam all the Muslims people are
rather curious that what will be the
content of this talk it's rather an
unusual topic I start my talk by quoting
a verse from the glorious quran from
surah anaam chapter number 6 verse
number 54 we face what is a idea a
phallus inna Yamuna Bai Athena Furcal
salam-o-alaikum and when those come to
thee who believe in our science tell
peace be on you it means that whenever a
moment whenever a Muslim comes to you
you should say as-salam-o-alaikum may
peace be on you
it's company that whenever a Muslim
meets another Muslim whenever a moment
meets another moment he should say
as-salam-o-alaikum may peace be on you
it's complicity the other words I quoted
was from surah nisa chapter number 4 was
the 86 phases what is a hurry to be
Tahiti Ohio yes an amine ha Aloha
inna llaha can ala kulli shayin ziba
which means that when a courteous
greeting is offered to you meet it with
a greeting still more courteous or at
least the same and Allah is careful in
keeping accounts of all things that
means whenever any person greets you
you should greet him with a greeting
which is more courteous or at least of
equal courtesy it's compulsory for
example if suppose someone wishes you a
salam-o-alaikum you should wish back
while it Muslim or not Allah if someone
says assalamu aleikum wa rahmatullah you
should wish back walaikum assalam wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuhu may peace
mercy and blessings of allah subhana WA
Ta'ala be on all of you
oh if someone says assalamu alikum you
can even reply waalaikumussalam the
words are the same but it is coming from
within the heart from the depths of the
heart from the bottom of the heart the
words are the same but it is still a
more courteous greeting walaikum A'Salam
or if someone says assalamu alaykum
warahmatullahi wabarakatu and if you
cannot improve on that at least say
waalaikumussalam warahmatullahi
wabarakatuhu
minimum of equal courtesy but there are
many Muslims who own companies
well what various employees under them
and when the employees when they wish
them
as-salam-o-alaikum the north for the
mama organs laughs some even don't care
to reply these Muslims they are going
against the commandment of Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala in the glorious quran in surah
nisa chapter 4 verse 86 tree says you
should wish back more courteously or at
least wish back with equal courtesy his
grid back the person with equal courtesy
its minimum let's analyze the various
types of greetings that we have in the
society and the most common of all the
greetings in English we say good morning
in africanus people say who you Mora
Osaka Bona in
chousen in most of the languages it's a
very common greeting good money and
suppose it's rainy day it's raining cats
and dogs
and if someone wishes you good morning
what is so good about that morning it's
raining cats and dogs the city is
flooded and here to say good morning
what is so good about that morning and
when we go to school and if you are
starting in English school every period
in the beginning of the day in the
morning when the teacher enters all the
students wish the teacher good morning
sir
it's compulsory and maybe the teacher
before he left his house maybe he had a
fight with his wife early in the morning
he may be closing that morning in his
heart he may be praying that never
should such a morning ever come in his
life but in spite of this when the
students wish good morning sir he has to
reply good morning
even though from the depth of his heart
he may never wish that such a morning
should come again yet he replies back
good morning what is so good about that
morning in which a person has a fight
with the spouse the best form of
greeting is a some greeting assalamu
alaikum peace be on you irrespective
whether it's a rainy day with this
raining cats and dogs whether you had a
fight with your spouse or with your
friend yet the greeting
as-salam-o-alaikum may peace be on you
is the most appropriate we have another
form of greeting especially among the
young people who go to schools and
colleges when they wish their friend
they say hi and if a young friend wishes
to his friend across the street
hi the friend will reply
and when you ask him what is the meaning
of high no one will be able to reply
what is the meaning of high no one will
be able to reply in Hindi that the local
language out here hi is a form of
disgust you know hi and English with
high-5 means something which is on a
height and another meaning of high is a
slang word for a person who's
intoxicated and people say I have been
to the party and I got high I got drunk
I got intoxicated is that a courteous
greeting in fact I say it is not a
greeting at all leave aside it being a
courteous greeting hi is not a greeting
at all the other common greeting which
most of us use is hello and if we look
up in the oxford dictionary the meaning
of hello it says an informal greeting
and the other meaning given in the
oxford dictionary is that to begin a
telephonic conversation to begin a talk
to start a talk on the telephone do you
know how did this idea come about that
to start a telephone conversation you
should say hello the person who invented
the telephone was Sir Alexander Graham
Bell and once when he was leaving his
house in a hurry the bell rang and
initiate an early response he said hello
so that we can read the person and the
person responds fast and again god of
the house soon this word hello to start
a telephonic conversation has stuck
since that time and even today everyone
uses it you use it and when I use it
hello to start a telephone conversation
but nowadays especially in Bombay
thanks to the MTNL that the word hello
is used more often in between a
conversation because when the sound goes
low hello can you hear me hello the
Oxford Dictionary says hello is used to
start a telephone conversation but in
Bombay its use move in between the talk
then the bending of the top and since
the time the mobile has been invented
and when the area of reception is not
very clear you have to use the word
hello even in between the telephone
conversation so maybe in the revised
edition of Oxford Dictionary they may
change the meaning hello can also be
used in between a telephone conversation
I fail to realize that why does the
Western world use any other form of
greeting than the one used by Jesus
peace be upon him why do the Westerners
especially the Christians use any other
form of greeting than the one used by
Jesus peace be upon him and if you read
the Bible it's mentioned in the New
Testament in the Gospel of Luke chapter
number 24 verse number 36 that after the
alesh crucifixion when Jesus peace be
upon him goes to the Upper Room to meet
the disciples he wishes them in Hebrew
Shalom Aleichem oh if you translate the
Hebrew into Arabic it means
as-salam-o-alaikum and if you translate
into English it means may peace be on
you the best and the most universal form
of any greeting is
as-salam-o-alaikum may peace be on you
and a beloved prophet Mohamed Salah
solemn Hamid built upon him was always
the first person to greet the people
many of the sahabas many of the
companions beloved prophet on many
occasions they tried to be the first
person to greet but they feel
the Prophet hamdulillah was always the
first person to greet and a beloved
prophet musa alehsalaam said it's
mentioned in sahih muslim warm number
three in the book of salam chap number
901 hadeeth number five thousand three
hundred seventy four abu huraira may
allah be pleased with him he said that
the Prophet peace be upon him said that
the rider should first greet the
pedestrian the pedestrian should first
greet the person who standing a smaller
group should first greet the larger
group that means if a person is riding
on an animal like house etc or a camel
or if he is traveling you know what he
gives like a car or a motorcycle he
should be the first person to greet the
person who is walking on the streets
that's penetrated a pedestrian should be
the first person who should greet a
person who's standing or sitting
similarly a smaller group should first
agreed the larger group at further
dimension in saheeh Muslim one number
three in the Book of Salaam chap number
903 hadith number five thousand three
hundred and seventy eight Abu Hurairah
may Allah be pleased with him he says
that the Prophet said that it is the
right of every Muslim on his brother it
is the right of every Muslim on his
brother that he replies to a salutation
whenever animal says Salam aleikum
he should reply walaikum A'Salam minimum
there are minimum five rights of a
Muslim on his brother
the first is replying to a salutation
and continues that seeing uremic Allah
when someone sneezes and says
visiting a person when he's sick and
following the funeral procession these
are the five rights of Muslim over his
brother and the prophet musa alehsalaam
he also said that a younger person
should first greet a person who's elder
a person coming down the flight of
stairs should first degree the person
who's going up the flight of stairs
these are the teachings of beloved
prophet musa la sala now how is it
possible for any Muslim to follow the
commandments of the beloved prophet as
well as how is it possible to follow the
commandments of allah subhanho wa taala
which is mentioned in surah anaam
chaplin was 6 verse number 54 which says
that what is eijah a fan Lavina human
una bi athena circle salam-o-alaikum
that when those come to deem who believe
in our science wish them
as-salam-o-alaikum how is it possible
for us to follow the commandments of
allah subhana wa ta'ala and the beloved
prophet unless you recognize that the
person in front of you is a Muslim how
is it possible for me to recognize that
this particular human being believes in
the sign of Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
unless I recognize that he is a Muslim
or is a moment
usually when you attend the conference
the delegates the way a label or they
wear a badge on which is mentioned in
the name of the delegate and his
designation or the police way comes from
if
it's a conference of intellectuals maybe
the profession is mentioned whether the
doctor or an engineer or an advocate if
it's the conference of specialists in
the field of medicine
the speciality is mentioned whether he
is a cardiologist a heart specialist
whether he is a neurologist a brain
specialist whether he is a urologist a
specialist of the kidney whether he is a
gynecologist a specialist in the disease
of the woman whether he the pediatrician
a specialist of the children the
speciality of that person is mentioned
this batch are a label which the
delegate where it's a sort of an
informal introduction if you want to ask
any question about the heart you will
ask a cardiologist if you want to know
about something about the pain some lady
that wants this will go and approach a
neurologist if you want to know
something about the treatment of the
disease of the children will approach
the pediatrician this batch is a sort of
an informal introduction it's a
requirement but every Muslim should also
have a label for example I'm wearing a
badge I have a label on which is
mentioned Allah any person whether
Muslim or non-muslim when he sees this
batch even if he cannot read Arabic he
will realize it is something in Arabic
and he'll immediately realize that this
person is a Muslim it's an informal
Russian introducing myself that I am a
Muslim there are areas of the batches
available and we have a great variety
and there's SAMHSA's foundation batches
mentioning la ilaha illa Allah Muhammad
Rasul Allah there is no god but Allah
and Prophet Muhammad SAW
is the messenger of allah subhanaw taala
we are batches mentioning Quran is the
word of God for universal guidance when
a person sees the batch a non-muslim he
may also be inquisitive not what is this
badge you're wearing what does it mean
Allah and you have an opportunity to do
Dawa he masks Quran the world of God
what is this Quran an opportunity to
talk it's not possible for all the
Muslim Ummah to wear a badge like the
one I am wearing
it's difficult it's not freely available
and it's also expensive therefore I
wouldn't say that everyone should wear a
badge and neither do I wear a badge
always I always this batch always last a
few times not always when I wear the
coat I wear a badge not always it's not
practical that every Muslim should wear
such a badge why don't we Muslims wear a
label which is being worn since ages and
it is already there in that community
since ages I am referring to the beard
and the cap but why don't be Muslims
where the label that is sport a beard
and wear a cap there may be many Muslim
brothers of mine whom asked me that with
the zotkin what does the cap and the
beard have to do with Islam do I have to
wear a cap and sport a beard for Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala to recognize that I am
a Muslim for Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to
recognize any human being whether they
is a Muslim or not he doesn't require us
to wear a cap or sport a beard
unless subhana WA Ta'ala is me again he
has the knowledge if you deserve jannah
heaven Allah will give it to you if you
deserve Jahannam hell
give it to you Allah doesn't require a
person to wear the cap or sport a beard
recognize whether you're a Muslim or not
but the question I ask that how will I
as Muslim who doesn't have in the gap we
will recognize whether the person in
front of me where there is a Muslim or
not how will I recognize how will I
follow the commandments of the glorious
quran in surah Anam chappathis was 54
that whenever those come to thee who
believe in our science
whenever the moments approach you
whenever the Muslims approach you wish
them a Salaam walekum how can I follow
this guidance unless I recognize that
the person in front of me is a Muslim or
not people mask me there be the zakat is
it a fart is it complicity to keep up
yard and wear a cap I have not come
across a single verse in the glorious
quran which says that it is offered to
keep a beard
the not a single verse in the glorious
quran the only place where the Quran
mentioned about the beard is in surah
taha chapter number 20 was number 94
which says collar abnormal he said Adam
peace be upon him tells his elder
brother Moses peace be upon him he said
that all son of my mother that artists
believethey wallah barossa don't hold me
by my beard oh by the hair on my head
this is the only words in the glorious
quran which mentions the word pure iron
peace be upon him tells his elder
brother Moses peace be upon him an
English angry that don't hold me by my
beard or by the hair on my head
indicating that her on a leash Salaam
errant peace be upon him had a beard
that's all this was doesn't say there it
is compulsory for every Muslim to keep a
beard but the glorious quran says in
several place
Atala what you're a fool in several
places in surah al-e-imran chapter
number 3 was the math hurry to in surah
al Imran chapter number 3 was done 132
in surah nisa chapter number 4 worse
than 59 in forum Ida chapter number 5
was tumour 92 in surah Anfal chapter
number 8 was number one in surah Anfal
chapter number 8 was number 20 in surah
anfal Shabnam it was through 46 in surah
new chapter number 24 verse number 54 in
surah noor chapter number 24 verse
number 56 in surah muhammad chapter
number 47 verse number 33 in fallujah
adalah chap number 58 verse number 13 in
several places including surah taha boon
chap number 64 was number 12 the
glorious quran says are - laughs what
your roster obey Allah and obey the
messenger it's compulsory that every
Muslim should obey Allah and obey the
messenger and its mission inside Bukhari
1 number 7 in the book of grass chap
number 64
how did number 780 no fee may Allah be
pleased with him he narrated that
evening Omar the son of Omar said that
the Prophet peace be upon him said that
dude opposite of what the pagans to keep
the beard and cut the moustaches shot
it's a commandment of the beloved
prophet let keep the bird and cut the
mustache is shorter it's further mention
inside Bukhari volume number 7 in the
book of dress chap number 65 hadith
number seven hundred eighty-one that
evening Oh Maud may Allah be pleased
with him he narrates that The Messenger
of Allah peace be upon him said that cut
your moustaches short and leave your
beard most of the scholars say that
keeping a beard is most palpable most
hobbies highly recommended or some
people say
soon at the market ah it's a highly
recommended Sunnah of the beloved
prophet while there are many other
scholars who say that because the
finance is a few la appear rasool obey
Allah and obey the messenger any
commandment of the messenger becomes a
fart on every Muslim so there are many
scholars who say that keeping a beard is
purpo many scholars see it is mustahab
highly recommended while some scholars
say many others say that it is affirmed
because it's an amar it's a commandment
of the beloved prophet any commandment
of the beloved prophet becomes a fart on
every Muslim but any Muslim if he is a
true Muslim a respected by that mustahab
or a fart he will keep a beard there are
many Muslims on both face the beard will
suit very well if they have a good road
there are many Muslims on faith the
Birdman or food I remember the first
time when I kept a beard when I was
starting the medical college and my
group was very sparse even now it's not
thick it is the same but previously it
was most pass you know just a few here
here and there it's when I start keeping
a beard one of our Muslim brothers said
masha'Allah you have a new run each
other the beard has thrown light on your
face and the beard suits you what the
Muslim brother was trying to do was to
encourage me that I should continue
keeping the beer
alhamdulillah but I knew that I file
looks this concerned the bill did not
sleepy you know just few heavier and few
earlier and a few hair there eating food
even now after so many years it has
grown a bit at home the Lilla but not
like many of us people who have good
growth alhamdulillah I have passed
through but I have a logic and I say
that those Muslims who have a good
growth and if the bear suits them
keep the beard inshallah they will get
to sum up because door being Allah and
His Messenger
but those Muslim who don't have a good
growth and if the beard doesn't suit
them and yet if they keep the beard to
follow Allah and Rasool inshallah they
will get most of up because imagine even
though the beard doesn't suit me
if the beard doesn't suit a Muslim lady
keeps for the love of Allah and Rasool I
consider her inshallah he will get most
about all those who keep the beard will
get the salam but the person on whom the
beard doesn't food and yet he keeps it
knowing wherever a doesn't suit him for
the love of Allah and Rasool he will get
multiple times most of our normally if
we analyze that all the human beings who
keep a beard if you take a survey
approximately more than three foot of
the men who sport a beard they are
Muslims more than 75% of the men's sport
a beard they are Muslims maybe about 25
percent maybe non-muslims but those
non-muslim whose put a beard they may
have a typical type of beard you know
with the mustache curled up so we can
make out that he is not a Muslim oh we
have a particular type of pure
resembling some other personality
indicating that this is not an Asami
type of beard oh he may wear an
additional sign like Atika owned by the
Hindus or wear across the sign of the
Christians so most of the time when the
non-muslim when they keep aboard
depending upon the type of the bird oh
the sign that they are wearing a cross
or a tika you can an defy that though
this person has a beard he is a non
Muslim so when you meet a person
sporting a beard
majority of the time more than 95% of
the time you can identify whether this
person is a Muslim or not
and for additional for additional
assurance we have another label I'm
referring to the cap people mask me that
is referred to wear a cap there is no
worse in the glorious quran saying that
it is a far to wear a cap neither did
our prophet said that it's a first to
wear a cap so I wouldn't say it's a
father but it is a Sunnah and if you
really say body one number seven in the
book or dress chap number 16 it's
mentioned according give me Abbas but
the beloved prophet musa alehsalaam when
he came he wore a black turban the
prophet whenever he went out he always
covered it unless you was in a state of
Mahara
he always covered that according to
Ana's bin Malik
he said that when the Prophet came out
he covered the head with a part of his
garment for the freedom say Bihari worm
number 7 in the book of breath
chap number 17 hadith number 609 enough
spin Malik man lobby pivot him he said
that in the year of the conquest of
Makkah when the Prophet entered Makkah
he was wearing a helmet the Prophet
always covered his head so it is a
Sunnah to cover your head whether it be
with a piece of cloth or like a head
covering with the Arabs way or a cap and
the Mohandas those were experts in the
knowledge of Hadees if they have to
verify whether there are weavers the
person who narrated is a seeker is true
or not
many of the mahadji's was launched they
do not regard the hadith of a narrator
who did not cover his head
with liver narrator did not give a
result the stones more they say we will
not accept his Hadees
so imagine it is a fauna to cover the
head and the cap it is so cheap it is so
cheap you know hardly cost about 10
rupees 15 rupees or 20 rupees the one
that I am very it's made in China
cost about an affair apiece it's a
harmless thing it cannot even hurt a fly
it is so harmless but it can do wonders
it can do wonders and I normally keep on
traveling alhamdulillah I keep on
traveling in various parts of the world
and people when they see me especially
when I'm in the western country who's
this man you know fine-looking man
wearing a coat coat and trousers and
wearing a cap it looks a bit funny and
many people who enter with last what is
this cap so I tell him it is the sign
it's my label I'm Muslim oh and a posh
new teacher Dawa where is the fuzziness
Lam and opportunity people wonder what
is this person you know wearing a funny
type of headgear to come and approach
you they are giving you an opportunity
to open your mouth it does wonders
people start respecting your Kundalini
it's a harmless thing it can't even hurt
a fly but it does wonders and suppose we
are walking in office which is being
owned by a non-muslim and if suppose he
does not like you wearing the cap it's
very easy take it out and keep it in a
pocket but the moment the office time is
over you can wear your cap back it's
you're right he's only paying you for
eight or ten hours a day working for him
but the moment you come out you can
raise a cap it's preferable to wait
always but suppose we have a certain
problem that you have to work in that
office and if it doesn't allow you no
problem
take out the cap and keep it in a pocket
it does wonders you know when we go to
the mosque alhamdulillah we see that the
majority of the Muslims they wear the
cap alhamdulillah
but when they come out most of them put
it in the pocket why what is the problem
are you afraid to identify yourself with
Muslim the outside are you afraid
what are you afraid of in the mosque
alhamdulillah wear the cap but when you
come out you put the label in your
pocket see in the mosque people
recognize our Muslim alhamdulillah have
been wear it there but when you come out
why do you keep it in a pocket and if
you asked your grandparents and those
elderly people they will tell you that
people respected this label the cap and
the beard and the non-muslims very often
when they wanted to hire a taxi a cab
they search for a driver who wore a cap
and a beard for that oh these are
Muslims you know they're honest people
they will not cheat us they will not
take us for a ride and if you have to
purchase something from a shop the
prefer go into a shop which was owned by
a person sporting a beard and wearing a
cap they will not cheat us they will
weigh the material correctly the laborer
had the respect but nowadays if you are
wearing a cap and sporting a beard oh
you're coming from when Ebola from
Dongri ah this person may be a good 9
you know it may be a hooligan it's a
shame that we Muslims we are to blame
we have spoiled the respect of our label
and it is true that there are some
Muslims
who misuse this label and they try and
show that the mash oh you know oh we are
brave wearing a cap and putting a bed
Mia by honor that agree want to go
around show that we are Metro there are
a few of us who has spoiled the name
therefore many Muslims say let's see I
don't want to wear a cap and pour the
beer
otherwise he'll think that I'm a good
nah I'm hooligan therefore I don't want
to wear the cap or the beer no people
argue so I tell them because of a
mistake of view of the Muslim brothers
who have quality labels why should we
our self stop respecting the label even
if I live with you for sake of argument
that every person wearing a cap and
putting a burden is not a good person
for sake of argument what I tell our
Muslim brothers at least you be the
first person who starts wearing a cap
and sporting a beard and say I don't
know about the other people at least I
am a Muslim who wears the label has a
cap sports abroad and I'm a good Muslim
I'm a good human being I don't cheat
I don't their lives I don't write I'm a
good Muslim you at least be the first
person to initiate tomorrow there will
be 10 people there will be a hundred
people there will be thousand people and
inshallah once again they respect for
the labels a cap and the beard will be
restored we cannot give this argument oh
you know because you know if we were the
label people think that we are bad here
hooligans we have to change the society
we have to bring back to respect which
our label has lost and there are many
Muslims who are apologetic who are
afraid to identify them several Muslims
you know why that if they wear the label
wear a cap and put the beard the people
may ask a question ah you are the same
Muslim who's allowed to marry more than
one wife oh you are the same Muslim
who is circumsized ah the same Muslim
who does not have alcohol
who keeps a woman in the Vale who
subjugated the woman so they afraid to
identify themselves as Muslims I'm
asking a question that if the area is
notorious an area which is notorious
there are gangsters live in that area a
normal human being will be a bit afraid
to go in that area but suppose if you
have a machine gun and if we know how to
operate that machine gun will you get
scared will you ever get scared to go in
an area which is controlled by gangsters
no you have the stun gun with you you
have the machine and you know I use it
similarly if every Muslim knows the
reply the common question asked by
non-muslims no Muslim will ever be shy
or afraid to identify himself as a
Muslim the reason we are afraid to and
the fires and Muslims because we cannot
answer the question which is posed by
the non-muslims and for this
alhamdulillah has prepared a booklet the
replies to the most common question
asked by non-muslims and the robber 20
common questions with non-muslim poses
about Islam to a Muslim and the answer
to these questions have been given that
booklet which will insha Allah be
printed if every Muslim masters reply to
these questions he will never ever feel
apologetic
to face the non-muslim he'll be proud
hamdulillah if I have to go out not
wearing a cap it is like a fish out of
water without the label it's like a fish
out of water
alhamdulillah this cap it does wonders
it helps me to do my job
it helps me to remain on the sirat
al-mustaqim on the hawk because identify
myself muslims and i agree and that i am
a person who follows the religion of
heart
every religion has a certain label the
Christians they label is the cross
linda's the label is all or maybe a
vermeil on Atika they were on the head
the Jews they were a small cap behind we
neither identify this is our Muslim cap
it's a Jewish cap small cap every
religion has a certain label but the
community we should be appreciated which
should be maximum appreciated for
wearing the label is the Sikh community
the six they are hardly 2% and the
population of India which is close to a
billion people less than 2% a six but
they are proud to identify themself as
six always they wear the label you know
the way that turban which is a
particular type of turbine the way the
tied and also have a beard they are
proud to identify themselves as six and
if any person wants to indicate that
this human being is an Indian coming
from India he will always focus on a
sake for example if you see in a cricket
match or any match which is going abroad
and if they don't identify that Indians
are there in the audience they'll focus
on a six though he's less than 2% he is
not an Indian which is the sample Indian
Wells and 2% a minority of a minority
yet when the people want to identify the
D than Indian they focus on a fake
because he's proud to wear his label
irrespective whether he and Rose himself
in the army or the Navy or their force
he does not give up his label and I was
shocked that when I'd been to Canada I
read a report that a Sikh
who migrated to Canada and was a citizen
of Canada the Canadian government they
objected that he cannot wear the turban
in the army
he fought the case in the court and he
won the case that even in Canada he was
allowed to maintain his label imagine in
Canada he wants to identify himself that
is effect and he won the case